there was a clip I wanted to play that I
think encapsulates the argument as to
why some people believe Israel
should do a land invasion in Gaza and
why it's necessary for them to do
everything possible to eliminate Hamas
uh the clip I'm going to play is from
Ben Shapiro who I think recently
encapsulated the argument he said they
should show basically no restraint in
finishing off Hamas as he puts it and
the US should offer material support and
then he lays out a series of escalating
events that isn't all that dissimilar
from what you lay out in your article as
to what how this could spill out to uh
into a bigger conflict let's roll that
clip and I'd like to get your
reaction so the real risk for Israel in
not finishing off Hamas right now is
that this is taken as a sign of weakness
as it certainly would be byah heah is a
far more dangerous terrorist group than
Kamas Kamas is a dangerous terrorist
group they just proved it by killing
1300 Jews Hezbollah currently has over a
100,000 highly sophisticated Rockets
aimed directly at the North of Israel
estimates suggest that wereb to fire all
of those Rockets we wouldn't be talking
about 1300 dead Jews you would be
talking about somewhere between 20 and
30,000 dead Jews day one if heah gets in
Israel will have no choice but to
unleash the Air Force if they unleash
the Air Force they're not going to be
worried at that point about civilian
casualties at all they are simply going
to have to eviscerate the entire south
of Lebanon and topple the regime in
Lebanon that support heah if that
happens Iran undoubtedly gets in and so
does Syria if that happens and Israel is
now faced with a with a full war in the
North combined with a war in the South
because they will not have defeated
Kamas that's the predicate if Israel is
forced to the wall the possibility of
nuclear exchange is extremely high that
is why it is very important that the
United States provide the material Aid
to isra Israel and that they also
dissuade kah from getting in it's why
Joe Biden has been warning heah not to
get
in what's your what do you think of the
Doomsday scenario that he lays out there
and what is your prescription on how to
avoid such a horrific
scenario there's part of the escalation
that I agree uh you know some of the
logic there I think is valid he talks
about a nuclear exchange I don't really
understand what that is because it's
only Israel that has nuclear weapons
Iran does not have nuclear weapons his
bua does not have nuclear weapons so I
don't know what the exchange there
really would be but the main problem I
have with that analysis is the
fundamental premise the idea that if
Israel doesn't destroy Hamas eliminate
it Hezbollah will view that as a sign of
weakness that type of sign of weakness
argument is what we're hearing all the
time in order to justify completely
senseless escalations that have been
utterly success unsuccessful the United
States went after the Taliban and
Al-Qaeda rightfully mindful of
al-qaeda's attacks on the United States
on 9/11 but some way somehow that
objective of taking out Al-Qaeda or
punishing at them there in
Afghanistan you know changed into a much
larger objective of bringing democracy
to Afghanistan and completely ending
evil and things of that nature which led
to a 20 year long
unsuccessful extremely costly occupation
of Afghanistan and guess what the
Taliban are still in charge in kabo so
for Israel to try to do the same which
he has tried before and failed seems to
me be extremely unwise and in fact
rather than Hezbollah looking at that as
a sign of weakness if Israel doesn't do
so it will be a sign of actually
wisdom of recognizing what is not
achievable and pursuing a much more
strategically wise strategy of being
able to protect Israel without falling
into the Trap uh and this fear of
looking weak only the weak fear looking
weak if you're actually strong you're
not worried about those things I mean
but then by that logic like what should
Israel be doing what is Justified well
first of all killing thousands of
Palestinians that don't have anything
with Hamas doesn't do anything to punish
Hamas and doesn't do anything to
actually add security to Israel I agree
with that but Hamas puts them in a very
difficult position in terms of using
human Shields right well it's not a
question about human Shields that area
is so heavily populated that you can't
go and and do Mass bombings and expect
that you're going to hit Hamas people
and not hit civilians uh the larger
problem of all of this and this is very
interesting I had conversations with
Israelis just immediately after this
happened is that Israel was under a very
false belief that it could sustain an
occupation of
Gaza indefinitely that it would bring
about small uh increases of instability
some skirmishes every two or three years
but overall it would be manageable and
as a result you did not need to resolve
the Israeli Palestinian conflict because
this could be managed that belief has
been completely shattered because Hamas
went in and killed more than 1300
Israelis that is not a cost that Israel
can absorb and find acceptable as part
of a broader occupation strategy it is
also incidentally part of the assumption
that the United States made by thinking
that it's going to go for a
normalization deal between Israel and
Saudi Arabia by completely ignoring the
Palestinian issue the world may have
forgotten about the Palestinians the
Israelis the United States a lot of the
Arab Elites very much so but the
Palestinians have not forgotten about
the Palestinians and now they have
reasserted their relevance in the most
most horrific way so you actually need
to go for an actual solution of this
conflict which does not entail some sort
of a military um elimination of the
other side keep in mind Israel was very
much part of funding and bringing about
Hamas as part of a strategy back in the
1980s to play Hamas a religious radical
organization against the PLO which
Israel at the time saw as a far greater
threat playing these different games
have only cost a lot of people's lives
on both sides and is not bringing about
any type of solution by now 50 60 70
years into we should have understood
that I very much agree with you in terms
of mourning the loss of Palestinian life
I mean the fact that so many innocent
civilians so many children have been
caught up in in something uh you know
have been senselessly killed by IDF
forces it is a completely unacceptable
thing and every morning I write reason
Roundup which covers this uh I think it
is important that people start these
conversations with mourning this loss of
innocent life because Israeli life and
Palestinian um has been you know
terribly lost but I do think you're not
fully tackling the question head on of
what should Israel do given that on
October 7th 1300 mostly innocent people
were slaughtered uh you know Holocaust
Survivors babies families all Sheltering
together it's not like Israel is
realistically going to say oh well now's
the time for diplomacy and to really
hammer things out like surely there will
be a military response and so what are
they justified in doing I mean you at
the beginning of this conversation also
said that activating 350,000 360,000
reservists is you know an unacceptable
way to respond to this and that that's
more manpower than they really need but
I'm curious from a more concrete place
what should Israel be doing right now so
let me first uh say something in terms
of uh the loss of life I agree with you
fully on that that and I think at the
same time it is realistic to expect that
there will be some sort of a military
response after such an attack whether
those attack such a response is within
the realm of international law Etc we
can discuss separately but the
expectation that there would have been a
response I think is quite clear this is
unfortunately the way most countries do
react to horrific attacks of this kind
but I had this conversation with an
Israeli security expert earlier this
week and and he insisted to me that look
the idea of taking at Hamas that's an
impossibility that's not what this is
about so I as what this is about that
said well this is about revenge Israel
is filled with rage because of what
Hamas has done and this is about revenge
okay if that is what the ca the case is
you asked you know what should Israel do
well what has Israel already done
there's already more than 4,000 people
killed at what point is the Revenge
satisfied and if it is only Revenge then
let's also be honest about the fact that
it may be an Impulse a need to do
something something because of the range
but let's not pretend that it's actually
adding security let's not pretend that
it's bringing a solution so I I want to
say that in the sense of saying you know
debunking the idea that the other side
who's arguing in favor of these military
uh interventions have a solution uh they
don't they have a Revenge plan and a
Revenge plan at the end of the day is
going to leave a lot of people killed
but it's not going to bring about a
better situation if you truly want to
get to a secure situation you do have to
start negotiations I understand clearly
that this is not the right moment in
which anyone on either side is going to
be open to it but the first step is
deescalate get a ceasefire Hamas is
holding more than 200 hostages those
have to be released they have no right
in taking those hostages those have to
be released the United Nations had a
resolution in the security Council
yesterday introduced by Brazil a close
us Ally it condemned Hamas it uh
condemned terrorism in the strongest
possible words it called for the
hostages to absolutely be released right
away and it also call for a humanitarian
pause it did not even mention Israel it
didn't single out Israel the United
States under divide Administration still
vetoed that resolution how can we say
that this is a path towards a better
future for all of the people including
the United States the Vance thing is
well the Vengeance thing is one possible
theoretical explanation but what about
if we take seriously the idea that
wiping out Hamas is actually the goal
then what types of things are Justified
or is that just an untenable Theory to
you it's not that it's not uh you know
that some people are not saying that it
is a goal they are saying that it is the
goal but I've never seen that goal be
able to be successful again we tried
that 20 years in Afghanistan with a
group that is not even as close as
sophisticated some as these other groups
uh as as Hamas is for instance so it's
not about whether it is some a goal that
you can justify as a result of the
horrible thing Hamas has done it's
whether this is actually a realistic
thing that ultimately is going to bring
about a better situation for all sides
including of course for the isra so I
can understand the impulse I can
understand the Revenge um uh desire
which unfortunately is part of humanity
but we have played this game many many
times and we're not seeing it leading to
a better situation and at some point we
have to have a conversation because it's
it's it's not going to be correct for us
to constantly do this and and 20 years
afterwards laugh about how you know why
wasn't the United States more uh
realistic about how to react to the 911
well we're having that situation right
now are we going to learn from that
wisdom are we going to tell a friend as
in Israel about our experience and
caution them not to repeat the same
thing given the fact that the idea of
actually eliminating Hamas is extremely
unlikely and the human cost in doing so
is not just the thousands of people that
have been killed right now but thousands
and thousands more both on the Israeli
and the
P hey thanks for watching that clip from
our conversation with TR parsey about
whether the US can and should deescalate
things in the Middle East you can watch
another clip right here or the full
conversation over here